hello i'm jane carter and I'm director
of coaching for hope and I think the
possibility of fifa world cup benefiting
africa is definitely there and i think
the key really from our point of view of
my point of view is to invest in in the
people who love football who follow
football but for such a big force for
change in Africa if it's used positively
so I think the key thing is investing in
the coaching infrastructure giving
people a chance to get out there and
play and focus on the people rather than
the buildings and then the whole
continent hopefully can really get
something out of this fantastic event
that do okay